dude
we traveled the world together man
mm-hmm like uh i mean dude put it there
we did we we wild boys sometimes my
dream job like like honestly like that
was me just piling on like jackass was a
huge success we just made the first
movie yeah and uh
luckily mtv was like mtv was still
shocked that we wouldn't do the jackass
tv show anymore and so i said well
what i will do is i want to do a nature
show and you guys need a nature
right
but we'll make it like a jackass nature
ship so it'll be
kind of like jackass but a nature show
which i don't know why i mean that's
just because that's all i watched like
that's all i wanted to do it was a
nature show yeah like steve irwin and
all that [ __ ] but
i got really lucky
kind of because that that was really you
and pontius yeah
and and you guys that kind of let me in
on you yeah we went it was so funny
because um like i i would just watch
animal planet or discovery channel and
one day chris was over
and we were watching and we saw this
yeah we watched manny like
jumping on shark like he and rackley are
riding in a little [ __ ] boat and
they're jumping out of the boat onto the
back of sharks and pulling the sharks
out of the water and these are legit
shocks like bull sharks lemon juice and
uh
and man he's doing it in a speedo like
[ __ ] look at that like we gotta find
these guys so right uh
we tried to find him when you went with
the
nurse shark diving
we were we were looking for that dude
like i already knew about manny i didn't
know how to find him but we had gooch
and everybody trying to find this dude
and uh
finally we tracked him down and it was
when you did the worm trick it was the
next season of jackass we were back in
florida i remember that the first day of
the unicycle off the air boat bite with
the gator right there the warm up in
their nose and
dude it was the first time we ever met
manny yeah we're at this everglades park
and we're in the parking lot just with
all you know getting the gear out
whatever knoxville's standing there
manny's standing there we see this
family walking in our direction and all
of a sudden their faces light up and
knoxville is like okay here we go this
is early on too so knox is still stoked
about getting recognized you know he's
like yeah and then they walk right
[ __ ] past knoxville to manny they're
like manny
that's so rad
and then uh and then it was and then
knoxville asked him i want to get bit by
a rattlesnake and manny says no no no no
no no no yeah yeah and and that was when
i went on to learn if manny says like
something's not okay
it's not [ __ ] okay and if manny says
something is okay that doesn't really
matter
that just means he'd be there willing to
be there you know like and that got us
around like having uh to be under the
supervision of professionals like manny
was our professional right he was just
the key that unlocked anything we wanted
to do on wild boys god damn like i'll
tell you like so we went and uh
we were shooting jackass first jackass
movie and we were in florida and we had
manny and he's like jeff you need to
swim in the black swamp i'm like all
right well we'll do it we'll do it like
no that was one that night this was uh
this saturday it was me and chris went
and swam with that was really i remember
the tv show days though that was like
the tv show it was it was before it was
uh black swan midnight was after jackass
one before wild boys okay
but this is during jackass one
uh
we went on our day off me and chris went
and swam the swamp with manny and man
he's just swimming down and bringing the
[ __ ] helicopter
right to us and like just letting go ten
foot alligators right in front of us and
they're mad and they they swim away and
it was scary [ __ ] but but we filmed it
and it was [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ]
epic that that's your day off like when
you take your day off and then you
choose to go play with alligators in the
swamp yeah and so then i go back to
florida
after
jackass
the first movie
and i called him and he's like jeff
i want to go to the black swamp at night
i'm like oh [ __ ]
well what happens tonight well the
alligators hunt at night but let's just
go do this you know do the
this is me
rack and manny yeah like entrusting them
to like you know i'm
i know how to snorkel i know how to like
but i'm not great at any of that like
i'm not super comfortable
you know just in in those [ __ ] guys
are they're ducks you know they're
they're yeah they're pure aquaman yeah
and uh
and they don't
have the best
equipment give me the i trusted them to
have the flashlights and everything
somewhere right we rack's got a camera
he's got a flashlight they give me my
snorkel gear they gave me a wetsuit
we go start swimming in the swamp at
night and i'm telling you you couldn't
see your [ __ ] hand in front of your
face pitch black i mean there's no moon
nothing and we get in the water
and we get in the water and then manny
starts [ __ ] swimming away
and i'm swimming with this [ __ ]
flashlight you can only see whatever the
beam of light it's like holding a light
saber underwater right and and every now
and then you pass over a big garfish or
a turtle or something and you're like
holy [ __ ] i'm and then i'm thinking i've
got this little red snorkel tip and i
keep flipping back thinking there's i'm
getting tracked
they think i'm a duck they think my
head's a [ __ ] duck and i'm gonna get
bit in the head by an alligator and so i
keep flipping back and also you're
hitting branches and i'm like oh there's
snake slips sleeping on top of that
brain i'm just [ __ ] scared to death
and luckily um and mark and mandy go off
trying to bring alliances they think i
need to see an alligator now and so they
swim up ahead so i'm just by myself with
this light while they're
charging
and of course manny comes back with a
10-foot alligator and [ __ ]
lets it go right like it fights itself
like you can if you're gentle with them
you can bring it back maybe it's got
like loose skin underneath yeah
and they have no concept of what's going
on so they don't feel threatened and
manny stays out of the eye line but he
lets this [ __ ] big ass i like it to
go right next to me and i'm floating and
it swam and hits both my legs swimming
away and i'm like did i get bit i don't
know what like this big powerful animal
just whacked me in the leg getting away
from us and i'm like and then my light
goes out
and i feel like you're describing the
silence of the land
i'm telling you like it was and i'm with
mark and manny who are just like
uh yeah
so brave so gnarly but like
ill-prepared we were totally ill
prepared to be in there
we got some cool footage like sure and
and that was that was a a day off yeah
that was a that was vacation for did you
count how many countries we went to on
wild boys we went to no i don't we went
to every continent except antarctica and
i we tried to go to antarctica we it was
really hard to do
it's a little one-dimensional too i
think it would have been cool i think
south georgia island would have been
cool you know we looked we totally
looked into it but it was that's been
he's got a way to get to yeah it was
like for us it was a ship we had to get
on
and go from at the bottom of argentina
and the problem is it was
paying for the whole crew and everybody
right like a week just to go for a few
days and back and really supervised by
not what wild boys was looking for as
far as the scientists and the right
right very supervised very hands-off
approach to which was great but that's
not what worked for us right
um i mean dude they did did you get
extra pages added to your passport yeah
yeah i had the fattest [ __ ] passport
and this [ __ ] passport still have it
it's the best it's totally still
happening do you have three holes poked
in it because yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh man my new passports are so
boring coming to that one yeah yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]